Juneteenth is a holiday that marks the
end of slavery for black people in the
United States it's a day to reflect on
painful history but it's also a day to
celebrate the future of black excellence
here are 4 stories of freedom resilience
and beauty in the black community the
dismal swamp is an environment that has
hazardous conditions associated with it
the heat you got poisonous snakes and
mosquitoes come out at certain times of
the year and it's unbearable but when
you think about some of the torture the
enslaved peoples endured
I think if most of us were living during
that day and we had an option to go in
the swamp and live freely I think a lot
of us would take that option from the
17th century until the Civil War escaped
slaves known as Marines found refuge in
the Great Dismal Swamp located on the
border of Virginia and North Carolina
the swamp was wild and in hospitals
nevertheless it was there that Runaways
created self-sufficient communities
almost entirely cut off from the outside
world for the past ten years
archaeologist Dan sayers from American
University has been studying these
settlements part of what I did was
develop this sort of research program
called the Great Dismal Swamp landscape
study most of my focus has been on
archaeological discovery you know sites
out in the swamp as well as historical
research and then of course trying to
understand it before we start our
research there was a sense people lived
in the swamp for a variety of reasons
but we really wanted to go in the swamp
and find remnants of their lives out
there and sure enough we've been able to
look at several sites associate several
of these different groups probably in
1790 eighteen and twenty-five or thirty
nail that we found resistance I'm sure
the population went up and down so very
strong potential for any given moment
for thousands of people that they went
out of the Great Dismal inform these
multi-generational communities it was a
radical form of resistance in a good way
The Runaways was game slavery risked
everything to be free even if it meant
living in the harsh environment of the
swamp one former slave who briefly lived
in the swamp was a man named Moses
grandi I've done family genealogy
research in which I've uncovered a slave
narrative by Moses grandi who I believe
is my great-great grandfather's uncle
this Edmond granted my great-great
grandfather's headstone who was born in
1827 he was a Waterman and a Boltzmann
on the dismal swamp canal which was
being hand dug and he describes very
vividly in the slave narrative how they
were treated what they endured how they
were tortured if you had that kind of
experience and you had an opportunity to
come out to the swamp and live freely
under you know challenging conditions
you're gonna have a hard time getting
them out of there
the idea of Africans setting up
communities and being in in charge of
their destiny in the swamp I don't want
people to ever forget this history
[Music]
I'll be very honest with you when I do
dr. King and I'm performing is as if dr.
King takes over it's like the spirit of
dr. King comes into the road if you
listen to the majority of his speeches
right now
he's right in line with what we're
dealing with today
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
my name is Stefan Ferguson I travel
across the world performing his the
Reverend dr. Martin Luther King jr. I am
the only person who is licensed by the
king of state to perform the works of
dr. King I used to be a DJ we took some
of dr. King's old records and as we were
mixing them in I began to emulate some
of dr. King's old records particularly I
have a dream a good friend of mine said
man you sound just like dr. Cain you
should really consider taking your work
to another level I realized that it was
a gift that God had given me to continue
the work and the legacy of dr. King and
free debris
from the prodigious hilltops of New
Hampshire let freedom ring I've been
performing as dr. King for about 15
years get a lot of requests to perform
in different areas from Madrid Spain
London England
I've been honoured to get recognition
from a lot of great people President
Barack Obama reached out to me I have a
letter thanking me for my work so that
was a very powerful recognition
I've even got that from King family
members
I speak for the entire family that we
know of no one who can actually sound
like my own children his cadence is
unique it has a slow southern drawl to
it but a sophistication at the same time
and Stefan just really flatters us all
with the way that he's able to bring my
uncle's voice back to life
I believe it resonates with people
because we're living in a time that we
needed with all the hatred the divisive
mnestheus e in the world I think it
really inspires people to stand up to
speak out I may get to the age where
it's gonna be difficult but I'll still
be trying to do it
[Music]
that would see children feeling insecure
about who they were because of their
skin color and their complexion but I
also witnessed that children were making
fun of each other based off their skin
color black children like calling each
other Blackie seems they here is like
nappy I witnessed this for a long time
so I created a song for the children
that I teach because I wanted to change
their perception of beauty and how they
felt about themselves and I want to
encourage them to love themselves I
[Music]
remember growing up and feeling very
insecure about the way I looked I
thought my nose was like not straight
enough it was too flat and I felt my
skin was dark also when you look on the
television the images that were
portrayed did not reflect who I was as a
black child after attending college I
took a trip to Africa that really made
me embrace and love who I was
I teach at a charter school called
hello.mat Davis Leadership Academy we
have what's called a girls school one of
the things we talk about is self-esteem
because I saw that many young girls I
taught didn't feel good about themselves
and they felt uncomfortable their black
skin so the do now question is do you
think skin color determines a person's
value or worth in this society I said no
because I don't think your skin should
define you in any type of way you have
to work hard and have a control people
say and keep our mind focused on school
so that we can make it to where we want
to be I think it's important to use
music as a way to inspire and to
transform people's lives I vowed to make
this song for all black girls to really
define beauty for themselves already see
a lot of the young ladies feeling much
more confident and much more outspoken
and they're much more willing to tell
their stories my black is beautiful my
black is beautiful my black is beautiful
it's what happens when children feel
good about themselves that transfers to
all the other aspects of their lives
there are many problems we can solve in
this world and my insists to make sure
that black women feel good about
themselves and black children feel good
about themselves because I think that is
the foundation of all our education
[Music]
mental health in the black community has
been a problem for decades
a lot of their plays into the stigma
about mental health and a reason why
people not want to get to help this
necessary
barbershops are a safe place for young
men of color barbers are only people in
our life that we allow to get close
proximity with us with a razor
we realized that partners become our
friends and that's really important
because I could use that same space to
work with barbers to talk about our
mental health my name is Lorenzo Lewis
and I am the founder and CEO of the
confessed project the confessed project
is a national grassroots movement that
is geared around building a dialogue
with mental health for young men of
color I had a lot of problems as a young
person my mother was incarcerated when I
was born into this world and losing my
dad at the age of 10 I didn't know how
to deal with it I would go to this
beauty salon every day after school and
it was a barber there's and I never
forget you know a lot of the nurturing
care that I got from him really
empowered me to want to do better really
want to empower me to do good in school
I realized that I'm not the only one
struggling a suicide is the third
leading cause of death for a young man
of color between the ages of 18 and 24
and a lot of this plays into communities
where there are a lot of violence and
toxic masculinity so the barber shop was
a perfect place to start the confess
project
I'm walking to a barbershop and and
accidentally if I could have a moment of
their time and then that moment turns
into an educational session thank you
all for being here today I think the
most important part is why I really came
in today if you really saw that I can
exhibit to you all how we can break
through our pain and how they're part of
their being our purpose our goal is to
not train barbers to be mental health
experts but the training to be mental
health advocates we're training them
with the skills of active listening
communication validation to not be
judgmental to be sensitive with language
so that their clients can be able to
open up and possibly go and get some
help and treatment that may be necessary
I've always been feeling in a depressed
state and I never knew why no I still
don't know why to be completely honest
was the first time I've ever heard a
black man talk about his struggles of
mental health there his emotions with
feeling like he's low for the like he's
in that hold that he can't get out of
and that's a feeling that I felt before
growing up it was a feeling that I felt
often is a feeling that I was feeling in
that time that I came to here I thought
it was very powerful seeing black men
coming together hugging and sharing that
valuable moment together and you could
see it in their eyes and an emotion
[Music]
since starting to confess project we
have now expanded to nine US cities
across the southern and Midwest region
it's really important to keep that
momentum going we realize that you still
have a lot of work to do it is one of
those things where we have to create
leaders and build a generation of
leaders so that they can be sustained
and also go out and help many more
community members that we may not reach
what I specifically love about my job is
that I get to work with that side of me
that I wasn't able to get that same help
with and help young men of color to
really thrive and to really become the
best version of who they are
[Music]